[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'élection du nouveau président du
département s'est faite ce matin dans
l'hémicycle du palais de la source
deux candidats se positionne à la
succession de nassimah dindar cyrille
melchior et jean claude lacouture et 50
conseillers départementaux présents
votent et c'est cyrille melchior qui
l'emportent avec une majorité de 26 voix
est un président qui rassemble
je vais être un président qui propose à
l'ensemble des élus de quelque bord
politique de travailler ensemble de
mettre en commun nos forces notre
énergie pour rester au service de la
réunion je veux être un président
rassembleur
cyrille melchior devient donc
officiellement le 12e président du
département de la réunion
la sénatrice nassimah dindar cède sa
place à l'homme qui était son premier
vice-président chargé des finances et
donc je salue son élection
je suis persuadé qu'avec l'ensemble
aujourd'hui de la majorité dans son
discours il a prononcé avec toutes les
collectivités je pense aussi également
aux parlementaires avec les maires les
présidents l'interco avec l'ensemble des
conseillers départementaux pour que nous
puissions définir l'avenir à construire
avec tous et pour tous l'élection de la
présidence achevé les conseillers
départementaux se réunissent pour
définir les élus qui siègeront à la
commission permanente ainsi que les vice
présidences
[Musique]